yeah
that's uh I'm not sure all of you um
another view I'll try
um
thanks uh to my talk and um
it's a little bit of a challenge to
help after Avi and
um
I guess I should also start off with a
little bit of a explanation of how my
talk might be connected with the theme
of
of the workshop but actually I probably
have a slightly easier time because if
you look at the exact description of the
workshop there is the word holographic
algorithms stated in there
but also partly because of that perhaps
I feel maybe I should
especially unless it's not here give
some introduction some very Elementary
idea what the holographic algorithms are
and what the flavor of this thing is
and then I would like to move on to some
survey as Peter described
dichotomy theorems which are basically
classification theorems of there's broad
classes of counting problems
and these are Samba product type
computations or partition functions
and every now and then I would like to
point out some possible connections with
many of the themes and expertise of the
audience who do tensor tensor Rank and
you know there are connections there in
many ways but I
because of time limitation I think I'll
not really dwell too much onto the exact
details
so in some sense I think the talk would
be so two parts the first part will be a
very Elementary description and
hopefully you get a flavor of what
holographic algorithms are
um
when Les gave this talk in the very
beginning about introducing holographic
algorithms and
um there was sort of a feeling that oh
my God he's got some very strange
algorithms that will collapse p and p or
shop PNP and I don't think in fact my
talk will give you that impression
rather I think it it gives you an
understanding of this extent to which
these techniques can do and the by the
dichotomy theorem which will be the
second part of the talk if we try to
describe to you that in some sense the
import of these holographic algorithms
is trying to carve out exactly what uh
what you can do with these techniques
within Sharpies so you have a complete
classification within Sharpie
um
so let me let me start with this Sharpie
everybody probably knows but let me just
one slide on it it's basically a
counting version of NP you have a NPS
decision problems is there a solution
Sharpie is how many solutions are there
okay so basically but I like to somewhat
bring your attention to the idea of a
perfect matching voice
so
um perfect matching
um
okay I can take this out
also staring in front of my words
no I have to move the slides good great
thanks
okay so so what is perfect matching I
hope to have just a single slide to
explain if you're not familiar with it's
basically you have a graph and you're
taking a subset of edges so that every
vertex has exactly one Edge incident to
it okay it doesn't have to be on a
bipartite graph even though you're
probably most familiar with but perfect
match
and there are two um
uh I would mention that uh for perfect
matchings on a general graph not just
for bipartite graphs you can actually
find if there's a perfect matching and
you can also count the number of perfect
matchings on a planar graph
these are two really fantastic
algorithms
and then
based on the idea mostly about the
counting on perfect matchings or
weighted perfect matchings on planner
graphs that I introduced these things
called match Gates based holographic
algorithms and they have a certain
flavor analogous to like Quantum
Computing you have fragments of
computation that are superimposed one or
another I'll explain some examples later
and they seem to introduce they seem to
achieve some exponential speed ups for
problems that otherwise you didn't know
how to do in polynomial time and then I
would like to move on to basically give
you some very simple problems and you
can see the flavor type of problems it
solves
so here's our problem okay uh
here's a picture first okay so you have
a graph a degree at most three
and then your task is to
consider orientations orientation of a
graph is to assign a direction of an
edge what either this way or that way
okay subject to the constraint that at
every vertex
it's not the case that everybody coming
in knows the case that everybody comes
out so one coming in two going out two
coming in one coming out is okay it's no
sink no sauce a very natural question
right
and this problem
um can be solved to count the number of
such valid orientations can be solved in
polynomial
so this is this
comes from a sort of a tradition of
these ice easing problem ice problems or
something and this this can be solved
exactly in this exact case of a degree
at most three
that that would not be a valid
so this is just an orientation and then
you demand in fact
um you should not have degree one at all
because you you can't do that right so
it's degree either two or three three
such problem
uh you're given a formula satisfiability
formula and uh it's a conjunction of
Clauses and uh there are three literal
three variable Clauses uh
it's a not or equal on these three
things so the local constraint is it's
not all equal okay
and uh
if you have some some other things which
will probably see later called the
constraint satisfaction problems you
have various different kind of
constraints like exact one or
so so so counting problem of exactly one
the three set question is is Sharpie
complete
and this thing says that if it's not all
equal per Clause then this actually can
be solved in polynomial so by this
technique again
so so this was a flat family of uh of uh
formulas that was introduced by
lichenstein the hurling 80s that you
draw down the graph representing the
graph of of the formula vertices
represent either literals or Clauses and
you connect them if you can connect with
them as a planar graph
the reason they have to be planner in
this setting is because ultimately it's
reduced to the perfect matching Problem
by custody and so I mentioned earlier
counting the number of perfect matches
so here's a
uh not explicitly sort of accounting
problem you have a graph
you want to remove
oh that there's a typo it's not a
planographic in general you have a graph
and you would like to remove a subset of
vertices and their incident edges
so that
um
the resulting graph is a bipartite so
you're given the planer not necessarily
bipartite graph
yeah planer but not necessarily
bipartite but the point is to remove set
of vertices as few as possible so that
the thing becomes bipartite
well still planar
if you talk about not the no deletion
but Edge deletion then you can imagine
that you have this bipartition of size
of vertices still there and some edges
being removed on connecting from left to
left and right to right and that will be
a next cut because you remove as few
edges is the same as to retain as many
edges
so that that problem
um
and now let me go to this
strange problem if you will
um
we are looking again as a planner graph
representing this kind of formula as you
ask the vertices and clauses
and it is
the best way to think about this graph
is it's like a 2-3 regular graph okay
every variable occurs in two Clauses and
every Clause has three literals
variables in this case monotone
okay so now what you want is to find the
number of satisfying assignments to this
here you want to find the number of
satisfied assignments in modulo 7.
so it's either zero or one or two or
three or four or five or six
so
why not it's a problem right
well why not is that it's actually known
that if you don't ask for more 7 then
this problem is number P complete so
it's as hard there's a restriction that
I just placed these twice
is not a real restriction in the
complexity sense it's it's as general as
you can
and furthermore in fact if you only look
for more two so if nothing that was even
odd
I think intuitively you would think
that's easier than myself
but this turns out to be uh NP hard on
the randomized reduction it's actually
technically a parity PR
oud
this result is a different phenomena
than the permanent being easy module
tool
and uh have seemingly house or the other
one okay mod 2 is it's hard yeah yeah so
uh
that one particular model was disease
and the other house yeah with the same
problem is it the same type of
phenomenal difference
I don't know
the explanation I was about to show you
furthermore 7 comes from a theory of
developing the theory of match Gates and
what holographic transformation they can
do
but it's not obvious of mod too
yes
one is one easy
yeah yeah we'll see that we'll see that
first reset no but for the other
five sets it's a similar like that right
similar in philosophical sense I'm not
sure
just to connect it more to the workshop
I mean all of these algorithms and
reductions to the determinant and in
that sense it's very similar permanent
mod 2 reduces to the determinant R2
doesn't reduce Mark three this problem
again you're going to reduce it by
series of reductions to determine by the
way we don't know what the the status of
this problem was 3 is
the similarity well taken but
there's a lot of it's not
obvious in the sense that
people mod three we don't know that when
you come up with your construction to
match Gates that you come up with the
system of polynomial equations that has
a solution mod 7 but otherwise not
that's some explanation yeah yeah that's
essentially that's what it is
um
but but let me let me show you the next
slides
so you can have four cents
and then the mod 5 works
and then you can have
um
you know actually mod 15 works
and
um so the mystery is that it's actually
a Mustang number that is controlling the
solvability of the equations but you
know it's finite number of prime numbers
right
we know that if you use this approach
then
exactly when it is a Mustang number as
the modulus then you can solve it I
don't have a proof that you cannot do
otherwise in polynomial time that would
be the NP versus Sharpie question so um
so this it's not a lower Bound in the
sense that I proved to you that for mod
7 in this case doesn't work for the full
set I just say that that approach will
not work that approach comes down to a
set of polynomial equations and is it
solvable in various finite fields and in
this case mod 15 actually works most
important
okay
so now what is this mysterious thing
about match Gates well here's in a sort
of a pictorial example of a match skates
it's just a graph fragment a planner
graph fragment with some designated
external nodes in the outer phase and
the edges have certain weights let's say
come from the complex view but it could
be from a finite view if you do it
and then the properties of this graph
in its perfect matching and I'll explain
this in a minute uh is assembled
together to form a tensor and that will
be called the signature of the
matching
so what are these assemblage of values
you look at the perfect matching value
of this which is you sum over all
possible perfect matchings
and for each perfect matching you
multiply the weights of the chosen Edge
polynomial
you first evaluate the perfect matching
polynomial on this whole graph
one entry of your tensor okay are there
signs in that perfect match in
polynomial you take signs or no no you
just take the sum of the products of the
weights now the weights themselves may
be negative but but you don't introduce
plus minus ones
you remove some external edges let's say
you remove this and this and of course
you remove the incident edges as well so
you end up with this graph this part
this is just introducing a weight
and then you evaluate your perfect
matching polynomial on that again
okay that will be another entry of your
tensor
okay
now by the property of parity
requirements on perfect matching a graph
has a perfect matching if and only at
least it has to be a even number of
vertices so if you had a non-zero value
for the perfect matching polynomial
evaluation which is non-empty sum of the
product
then you can't remove just odd number of
external vertices and still expect to
have a non-zero so I'm asking you to
consider all two to the four different
ways of removing external vertices in
this particular case and there are
actually at most eight entries will be
non-zero
make sense
okay so that you assemble together into
a tensor of area D4
foreign
match Gates is basically a weighted
graph with some external nodes with an
embedding of a planner embedding and you
think about these external nodes either
as output nodes and input nodes now at
this point it makes no difference it's
just
external nodes and you can assign
perfect matching evaluation on the graph
fragments after you remove certain
number of external nodes the distinction
of considering as output or input or
generator recognizer in this language is
that you are going to about later on
about to transform them as either
contravariant tensors or covariant
tensors so you're going to transform
positively or by the inverse matrix it's
test by the way okay
and you'll see that why why this makes
sense uh so so technically they come
into different varieties but at this
point it doesn't
so now this is the polynomial I refer to
you sum over all possible perfect
matchings of the products of its weights
over the edges in the perfect matching
you think of a subset of the external
nodes you remove that subset of external
nodes from the graph and you get a
subgraph
and then evaluate that perfect matching
same polynomial on that subgraph and
this gives you an entry in your tensor
and these entries are indexed by subsets
and you assemble them together and that
is called the standard signature okay so
so is it clear so a match gate is just
this planner
graph fragments with weights and you
have external nodes and you think of all
possible ways of removing external nodes
and you consider perfect matching
properties of those
the reason you're going to consider this
removal is that basically you're going
to connect these match Gates piece by
piece together in this big big huge
graph where you're going to think about
all possible ways the entire graphs
perfect matching is going to come out
about and they will be classified into
how these nodes are going to be
externally connected or internally
connected and when it is externally
connected it's effectively the same as
removing this vertex from the
consideration of the perfect matching
Within
okay
so kind of tinsel is it because
evaluating the polynomial just yields a
number now
so at the moment I have not talked about
you know the tensor transformation
really it's just what's this is what's
called the standard signature so it's
just directly combinatory defined by the
perfect matchings okay
so hopefully it will be
is fine
or it should be R sorry
just either a recognizer generator the
reason I have these two things is
because one is going to be transformed
later on by basis Transformations
contravariantly and the other is going
to be covariant and they're going to
come together hopefully some example
will become clearer
so
supposedly we have a proof and hopefully
the a joke too and hopefully they're not
the same
um
I want to give you
the same and you'll be the judge if it
is okay
so we're going to have an attempt to
collapse shopping with P this
as I told you I'm trying to give you an
intuitive sort of guide tour and and
some of this is from dating the back
days of when we start looking at them
and uh and they these are pretty you
know strange algorithms if you will and
you'll see that it sort of just misses
and the question is is that a good thing
or bad thing
and I would like to argue that it just
misses and gives us these dichotomy
theorems
so again you have an instance and here
here's an instance think about this as
an instance okay you have variables
coming into Clauses there's a planar
graph okay and what you want to know is
the number of satisfying assignments to
this is that clear so you have this big
graph and you know by definition the
size n that's the definition
so we're going to allow yourself to do
some juggling transformation as long as
it doesn't become more than polynomial
size that's polynomial time reduction
right okay so we're about to replace
these pieces by match Gates
so imagine that these pieces are going
to be pieces of this graph fragments
that I displayed to you and now think
about all the possible perfect matchings
of this graph
and you classify them according to
whether or not this Edge is in and this
Edge is in and this Edge is in and this
okay you disregard what happens in the
perfect matching Within
and then it becomes an exponential sum
of all possibilities how the perfect
matching intersects with these external
connecting edges and for the given
pattern of the external connecting edges
what is the perfect matching of the
whole graph that is consistent with that
and now a moment reflection I don't know
if it's a moment but some some thinking
will convince you that it's in fact the
sum of all these external patterns
there's exponential sum already there of
the products of the all possible
internal exponentially many
possibilities of perfect matchings and
every one of the perfect matchings with
its weight assembled together when you
multiply it constitutes in a global
perfect matching that's consistent with
this external pattern
make sense so this whole sum then
becomes a sum over these external
patterns of the signature entry that I
just told you what what the signature
entry is is this internal perfect
matching assemblage of all possible sums
of perfect matchings of their values and
you multiply them all out that will give
you the perfect matching value of the
whole thing
and by custodians algorithm you actually
can compute that in polynomial time
you don't compute that by actually
summing over all possible external
patterns and trying to assemble them
right but theoretically you know
mathematically it's the same quantity
and you compute this otherwise by the
custodian algorithm
okay
so now let's let's look at what really
what we want in this particular case you
have or of three literals and so on
right so what is or well we computer
scientists would say an or is just a
truth table of 0 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 right
it can't be any simpler than that it's
indexed by three bits zero zero zero
gives you no okay I don't like the zero
zero zero that's the or function at
least one of them has to be one
makes sense it's very Elementary here so
so this entry will be zero zero one this
will be the zero one zero and so on and
so forth that makes sense so this is the
Boolean or function on three bits
okay
now what about a variable that is going
into two clauses
well the variable can either be zero or
could be one
but it cannot be zero and one right it
has to be consistent so it is
represented by this particular Vector
it's indexed by 0 0 or 1 1 0 1 1 0 are
forbidden okay it's the binary equality
function
it's variable appearing consistently on
clauses
good so that's that's how you can assign
you're going to assign the signature
here and the signature there this is
going to be a Boolean or signature and
this is going to be the equality
signature on the variable
okay
so let's look at a schematic instance
this is too simple to be of any real
interest but it illustrates the idea you
have three variables on the left and two
Clauses on the right
and what you want is to consider all
possible ways of these six edges you
know two edges coming out of x two edges
coming on the y two edges are common to
see that are either zero consistently or
one consistent three per each variable
right you have two to the six
possibilities
and you really have two times two times
two valid possibilities okay
on the other side you have these two
conjunction of Clauses where both on or
of three bits right so this thing says I
won't have at least one one coming in so
it's the zero one one one one one one
one one one
and I want this thing to be 0 1 1 1 1 1
1 1 1 okay and so what is the Boolean
end on these two constraints you just do
the tensor product
okay see so this is how tensor product
now comes in you have an A dimensional
vector
tensor a dimensional Vector both are the
representation as a truth table of the
Boolean or bits on Boolean or on three
bits
when you multiply
it wants to be both to be true so the
product is a zero times one or one times
zero or one times one you want it to be
so it's one times one you want both to
be yes
yes
stop me if if this is not clear this
should be okay
all right so
on the left hand side you want a
consistent configuration coming out
which is going to be the tensor product
of these four dimensional
tensors or vectors we have three of
those and an entry is going to be 1
times 0 times 0 for example okay what
you want isn't a one times a one times
one that will correspond to X being
false false y being true true and Z
being true true okay so that will be a
consistent assignment of all three
variables and this whole 64 dimensional
Vector will have zero ones and every
entry will be a zero one in this
particular case and it will be non-zero
if and only if it corresponds to a valid
assignment of all three variables
and on the right hand side you have
these two Boolean or you want to do the
tens so you also get uh
consistency issue on both being
satisfied okay
all right then what you want is to do
the stock product
it's a 64 dimensional dot product
in this tiny case here okay and then the
entry in the product is going to be 0 1
times 0 1 and it will be one both one if
and only if both are consistent so it's
a consistent assignment that satisfy
both clauses
and when you sum them all up then it
becomes the number of satisfied
assignments
so if you can compute this whole thing
in polynomial time as I told you it is
sort of like looking at the as a match
gate so therefore you can perhaps
compute the whole thing as a global
perfect matching
by castalian's algorithm then you would
have been able to compute this whole
thing in polynomial time and that you
would have solved the sharpiece the hard
problem
this was our joke
come on smile I miss it
right okay
now of course the uh
the kick is that they aren't possibly
match gates for one but not for the
other you know I sub postulated there
are match case that will give you this
this uh signature but it doesn't in one
side or the other one side does but the
other side doesn't so then there's this
next idea which is you do some basis
transformations to perhaps make it so
that it's realizable
okay so this is the the real name of
holographic algorithm comes in here so
we're going to do a transformation on
the basis and we're going to think and
this is why it's not just assemblage of
values I'm thinking of it as a tensor
because I'm going to subject to a
transformation of either the
contravariant or the covariant tense
okay
so at this point I will think about this
formally uh I have a tensor that's
subject to a transformation by matrices
and I like to for example realize this
zero one one one one one one one
okay I want to be it so that after the
transformation is actually a zero one
one one one one one one there are no
match Gates that will directly do this
but I want to show you that it's
possible to do it after transformation
okay
now what is good about the
transformation well this product this
dot product is going to count the number
of satisfying assignments that's the
quantity we want to compute and we if it
is somehow made into a match Gates thing
and match casing then I can compute this
thing without multiplying out this
exponential sum I'll do it differently
right
but for the stock product I could
transform it just by the middle by
inserting some in you know invertible
transformation matrix t to the tensor 6
in this case
and by tensor product it distributes so
I can do this t to the 6 by T to the 2 t
to the 2 t to the 2 and this T inverse
to the 6 to T to the inverse 3 and T to
the inverse three this is just a
mathematical equality
no computation taking place here okay
this is just a near stating of a fact
that the two quantities are the same
and the problem without this earlier in
this slide was that I can't quite get
match case to do both sides actually I
can do this side but I can't do this
side
and uh
now what if I after the transformation
after suitable choice of the T I could
actually produce a match gate whose
eight entry
is in fact the signature of a eight you
know an external uh three external
vertices match gate signature okay so
that's that's the point
and if I could have realized that I can
find a t and I somehow produce a match
gates for you and its signature is this
why it's called holographic you'll see
in a minute because I'm sort of
combining the truth value of the actual
perfect matching values by the entries
values of the T this this strange T
whatever it is okay the transformation
so let's let's think about this so at
least now mathematically
we want this
and we want to find a certain basis
transformation which is a two by two
Matrix okay and I will just choose this
would choose this where Omega is the
third root of unity
and I wish to somehow after this
transformation it becomes something that
is a match case signature
okay and if I can't do that on both
sides then I would really have collapsed
with me okay
so let's look at this what is going on I
would like to have the inverse Matrix I
can do either way if you do the inverse
Matrix of this two by two and tensor to
the 3 you get eight by eight and then
you're gonna multiply the zero one one
one one one one one on the left so
imagine that you have this one one one
one one on on this side let's keep this
in mind so yeah
zero one one one one one one one one
okay so you have this
Vector sitting there
and I will now compute this particular
matrix it's inverse I'll do the tenses
three and I get this Matrix out and you
just trust me this I compute it right
because for the younger people in the
audience they're doing it in real time
all right so I have this now
now
's Matrix
and I wish to come out with a vector
with a dimension that is the signature
of some match Gates okay
and of course this is all somehow all
the blue here I mean how did you choose
this and how do you know if it's a magic
is realizable and so but don't worry
about this for the moment okay if if I
succeeded you can argue
right
so what is the zero one one times this
well this that's simple I mean that's
just adding up the last uh rows right
last seven rows so even even you know we
all folks can do that so let's do that
right so you're going to multiply you
see you can add Omega Omega Omega minus
three Omega to cancel minus more minus
one minus one plus three cancel and then
that part also cancels
except
so you in fact will come out zero
wonderful
so this is what sort of the
holographicness comes out it's yeah
multiplying things with these truth
values with things that completely
abstract like Fourier transform type and
you're going to reassemble these values
superimposed on them by these values and
then you get a zero which then you
reinterpret as if it's a Boolean value
okay
so that's zero and I I hope you just
believe me that these are confused
correctly as well okay
and and and the upshot is that this in
fact is the signature of some match
Gates you actually can design a match
gate whose perfect matching value when
you remove some external nodes does give
you this
okay
so I
I would like to add first to hide yeah
yeah yes at the beginning all of your
tensors live in a space where you have
sort of two variables for each Edge even
even this a and so you can interpret it
that this is like some some free of well
it's a one variable leaving on two edges
they have to be consistent that's them
and this mattress is small two by two
Matrix is like changing this basis
that's right yes that's right it's a
basis transformation that's right
okay and that's why you know I'm
changing the tense so contravariantly or
covariant and they they this is where
perhaps it's a good point to say
conjugate reverse covert you want to
maintain this dot product
and so therefore you would like to have
the transformation to be inverses of
each other so so that the value is
unchanged when you did this
transformation
and so now where comes seven well it
turns out that over seven this you you
can do both sides
so the completely uh
omitted mentioning any theory behind
this so far it's just you know gee this
is great uh y7 how do you prove it's
just seven or
um and what about other things like like
these so there are
you know a substantial amount of work
has been done to understand what can be
designed what
properties a match case signature must
satisfy what kind of transformation it
can become and you argue uh sort of the
realizability question and you have
decision questions there
okay so this
is developed and it's under that theory
that you can't try all of them right so
obviously some understanding behind this
I'll just encourage
those of you who are interested in
please you know come talk to me or look
at some papers and it'll be a good deal
of material there
but now I'm sort of trying to segue into
another part of talk where I try to give
some hint of the dichotomy theorems
which is
build on this uh some of them anyway so
there are
times where you prove things that can or
cannot be done and it frequently
eventually comes down to a point where
you have a set of algebraic equations
and you say can you solve them
okay here's a sort of a pretty random
example okay you you come up with these
quantities and you say I would like to
set it so that there are solutions of X
and Y and as T no zero such that these
three are the same and non-zero and the
last is zero so first if that happens
then your desired match Gates happen or
your actually in this case your hardness
proof will go through
okay so it's a sort of a requirement
expressed in terms of algebra equations
actually can prove this for every C
other than one that this is true but for
c equal to one
the proof fails
and not only that it really corresponds
to perfect matching and match case
signature on the underline this and if
you could have proved this then you
would have collapsed
in some sense what I'm about to say now
is these dichotomy theorems now is to
carve up
a a wide class of these problems that
are some of product computations and
what you'd like to prove is that in
every single case it is either in
polynomial time or Sharpie complete
and you leave nothing in between and
these proofs sort of
tells you that exactly when it fails and
when it fails it happens to have this
very non-trivial algorithm
and and this is sort of a perhaps a
point I will come back at the end of the
talk but it's sort of like
if P were to equal to Sharpie
then it would be very hard to imagine
that somehow the proof will just elude
Us by knowing this on
you know unsuspecting algorithm which we
happen to have discovered in the 60s or
70s
but how come you didn't you know what if
something that you didn't know
that makes sense
um I'll come to that later
National functions
yeah these are rationals the team bursts
there is
just a simplifying this is no big deal
yeah you can have two variables in TNT
Primary in Cry The T times T Prime equal
to one
so now I would like to move to at least
this describe some of the
accounting theorems that have been
proven in this
uh it comes at least in three different
Frameworks graph homomorphisms
considering satisfaction counting
problems and Holland problems
so what is graph homomorphism here's the
definition of the partition function of
the graph homomorphism you're given a a
matrix a symmetric complex Matrix in the
undirected case
okay so an arbitrary K by K Matrix
and uh uh the input to the problem is a
graph an undirected graph G if you think
of this as n by n size that's the
variable and K is fixed
and then you
can suppose sound of a
subvertices of G with one of those K
values you think of this K as K
different colors perhaps
okay all spins up and down left and
right
and then for a particular assignment of
the spins you look at all the
and you go over to the Matrix and say
what would the edge value be so if you
assign the two vertices as a one two
then you go to the Matrix and you look
at the eight entry a12
okay and you multiply all of them so
this is called the partition function of
the graph homomorphism now
if this if this Matrix let's imagine the
graph
think think of this example let's say
you have a 0 1 1 1 let's say okay so
then you're saying I'm assigning
vertices as either 0 or 1.
okay and then on every Edge you would
like to avoid the case where both sides
are not taken
so you like to pick subset of vertices
so that every Edge has at least one side
is picked
right and so what is that problem
yeah vertex code right so that's a
Vertex cover and if you do something
like
to do something like a three by three
then you're assigning three different
names to the vertices so that uh every
Edge looks around and say you should not
be the same
color so so
problem with you in the audiences
okay so I I'm trying to explain that
these are very Elementary things okay
you just think about it and the
perspective is that this is a broad
generalization of all such sort of
locally specifiable Edge constraint type
questions it's a special case of the
constraint satisfaction
thank you
oh I have an example here so this is the
K coloring
all right so now the dichotomy theorem
in this particular case
and it's following a lot of partial work
where for example the initial work by
Dire and Greenhill talks about zero one
matrices and non-negative matrices and
Rios and so on
is to say that if you give me an
arbitrary Matrix
symmetric complex valued then this
quantity whose input is G output is this
value
is either a computer going polynomial
time or is Sharpie hard
that's sort of the
example of a dichotomy
yeah so so the
so the computational model is really
some sort of a side issue but you could
be very precise so you can think about
them as algebraic numbers for example
and since the K is fixed
then there's no question of what I mean
by this algebraic number as of output in
this field
and um um but it's more than that I mean
I I I can talk to you a sideline it's
it's you know it's only involving
multiplication Edition so as long as you
have a model where multiplication
addition is Meaningful then this is
okay
um now the graph homomorphism problem
can be viewed as a very special case of
constraint satisfaction you have a
binary function
every Edge has this binary function
sitting on it and you have both sides
coming in and you just give the value of
this constraint
and in general you have the constraint
satisfaction problem where
um you know you have arbitrary finite
set of constraint functions
and an instance of the problem is a set
of variables that take values between 1
up to K
and then a set of constraints taking out
of this set of constraint functions they
apply onto the subset of their variables
and then you think of all possible
assignments and you sum over of the
product it's a sum of product partition
function again
and there we have another dichotomy
theorem
it's the same statement you give me an
arbitrary f
uh the problem is either going to be in
polynomial time or Sharpie hard
but there's a quite a bit of a different
flavor this theorem uses the previous
proof which was uh pretty long
but there is a flavor in which this is
different this dichotomy really tells
you what set a will give you the
polynomial time Z sub a okay it's an
explicit
explicit is a very overworked term here
but but I think you all agree with me
that it will be explicit okay
um
in a nutshell it's sort of like some
sort of tensor prod so this a I'm
describing for which you're going to get
polynomial time partition functions are
tensor products of Fourier matrices with
some rank 1 modifications on top of it
being a little vague because it's really
a
it's not a simple sentence description
I'm lying a little bit
it's decidable in polynomial time even
using a thesis result by a girl who was
a student of lenstra and that takes
quite a bit of work to get that to being
polynomial time to be decidable but it's
decidable that's clear uh now the
difference here is that here we have a
strange situation where we prove to you
for every find I set that defines the
CSP problem the problem is either in
polynomial time or Sharpie hard what
does that mean that means that the f is
fixed and the instance of n variables
and M constraints taking out of this F
is applied and that's an instance and
you ask what is the solution this
computational problem input set of
variables invocation of these F's and
output the value of the sum of product
is either going to be in polynomial time
or Sharpie hard okay but we don't really
have a way to tell
it's not a contradiction okay
we don't have a way to tell if you give
me 17 functions F what case it belongs
I mean this is not desirable we don't
know if it's not decidable we just don't
know a decision procedure it in fact had
a predecessor paper a very beautiful
paper important paper by bulletov where
the constraint functions are restricted
to be 0 1 valued
okay
and his proof uses universal algebra
techniques and it was also the situation
where for quite a number of years that
it is known to have a dichotomy this
proof but it was not known as his
dichotomy criteria is decidable
and this was rectified by a paper by
Martin Dyer and Richard
so
you asked me for example what is the
best you know in terms of decidable
dichotomy it's the case where this is a
paper with pinyan 2 that if it's a
non-negative valued f
so if all the F's are non-negative
valued then this dichotomy theorem is
decidable
but it's when it has negative values or
even complex values the situation
becomes in some sense really tricky you
have cancellations
okay and and this is in some sense where
the holographic Transformations is
trying to take advantage of the
cancellations is a source for which it's
very efficient algorithms can arise so
this is where some strange magic can
happen
but nevertheless we have a dichotomy in
this case
um
hold on I'm gonna I think I'm running
out of time so so there's this third
framework called the matching uh Holland
which is sort of edges are variables and
vertices are constraint functions
perfect matching is one such example
obviously Edge coloring is another okay
and we currently for example have a a
dichotomy that includes Edge coloring
problem which has been opened for at
least several decades that so what's the
question you color edges with copper
different colors
and at the vertex the constraint is that
they're all different
okay and you want to count
the total number of valid Edge colorings
some more products again and we show
that this Holland dichotomy implies this
I think I'll stop here um
professions if we go back to this Matrix
one where you
do you know what kind of subset let's
say I fix the size of the Matrix a by K
once and for all do you know what uh the
nature of the subset that is indeed is
like I mean is this a closed subset is
it neither open nor closed is it
isolated points is it are there no we we
can describe it we can describe this set
very explicitly for every K so it's a
positive dimensional
yeah that was my next question positive
demand
what do you think by positive
dimensional I mean it has
like this oh no no no no no no no no
it's it's definitely a positive
dimensional but it's not full
dimensional that's what your question
could be full Dimension yeah but is so
is it is it the zero set of a collection
of polynomials is the next question is
it describable
it has a rank one modification for
immediately you have the diagonals to be
arbitrary for example
but that's a linear space arbitrary
diagonal yeah so that's not a problem
you have some arithmetic conditions I
mean is it yeah that's what I want to
know is an arithmetic you asked for
Dimension right well that was my first
question oh okay what's your second
question I believe you answered it okay
it's positive dimensionally right right
what is the do you know the dimension
is it so our whole spaces Dimension K
squared is this Dimension One or k
squared minus no no it's not K squared
that would be full Dimension no it's not
no no
but you're you're is it square root of K
pay or k squared minus one is it a hyper
surface probably not it's probably very
small it's symmetric so that's not this
case
I can do this calculation in my head
right now but it has a very explicit
description but it has a several stages
it's I would guess it's around K on the
order of K okay so I could be missing a
total space so what's the nature of the
description is the question is is an
algebraic given by arithmetic conditions
yeah that's cool it's it's a uh so you
you know what a Fourier transform Matrix
is yeah you take tensor products of
these guys
arbitrary
and then it comes in two varieties the
one that's called a bipartite type and
one is not
you can put in the bipartite case you
can put in the sort of off diagonal
blocks
and zeros there
or it is not a bipartite case then you
have a further slight restriction on
them and you put on the diagonal
directly and then for either case you
can do some rank one modifications on
these so so this is this scripture some
some matrices a which has property or
all or the characterization of those
which do
this is the description of all the A's
that will give you
polynomial time computable Z sub a
assuming p is not equal to Sharpie
everything else is Sharpie hard one day
somebody proves P equal to Sharpie the
theorem still is valid it's just
meaningless
so the first part of the talk we were
talking about you know planting modular
various numbers and then the dichotomy
theorems I didn't see it so yeah that
that that's separate yeah I I have
honestly too many different things I
want to say and it's they are not let me
just and perhaps say one more thing
which I didn't even get to say which
moves back to the first part
I think so we have some dichotomy
theorem and these are not for the
general domain called the general domain
problems these are copper bigger than
two case the variables take more than
just zero ones if the Kappa is equal to
zero one we have a much more explicit
descriptions of what the tractable csps
are okay and uh it's in that set where
we have a closer connection perhaps with
the stabilizers and orbits that people
here are mostly interested in and
there one of the thesis which is only
proved for the Boolean domain symmetric
set of functions is the following
all of these problems these CSP type or
you know let's think about the spin
systems for now
um it is
it comes in exactly in three types
those which are polynomial time
computable
and then those our lump the second and
third for now that are Sharpie hard so
that's the first dichotomy coming up
but then between those within those that
are Sharpie hard it actually comes in
two different kinds those which are in
planner input that are solvable in
polynomial time but in general case will
be sharply R and those which are
shopping hard even for planner cases
and then this the statement says that
the middle
class those which are just planner
solvable in polynomial points but
generally hard but precisely those which
are transformable on the holographic
transformations to the match Gates
computation
and I think that is really perhaps the
real import of the introduction of the
match case that it carves out this class
of algorithms that are planner in
polynomial time but in general shall be
hard
and there's this sort of a universal
algorithm which is basically the
holographic transformation to the
Castalian algorithm
for this class of problems at least this
is summer products of local computation
now this thesis is only proved as I said
for the Boolean domain symmetric
function set in and some asymmetric
functions but not totally proved in the
mode
and you know there are lots of open
problems in in the Holland framework and
and all of this so I'll be very happy to
have more young people working on this
maybe I'll just mention some
papers that you can look up
okay
the description of the good step a very
elegant discrimination